i'm really excited to give this talk
especially because yesterday we held a
workshop on mathematical modeling so i
think especially for those who are at
that workshop this will be a really
interesting way to see how you can use
these models
and for everyone else who knows
very little about mathematical modeling
it's still a very interesting
substantive issue
one which would be difficult to answer a
question which would be difficult to
answer without some type of modeling
like this and i'll explain that a little
more as we go
i should first say this is a
collaborative project with timothy
mentioned
was a student at the time stephen
goodrow who was here yesterday with the
modeling workshop and has been a mentor
of mine for
a while and matthew golden who is
currently the director of the hiv aids
division at the seattle
public health seattle in king county so
this project actually came out of a
collaboration that we an ongoing
collaboration that we have with the
university of washington and the health
department in seattle
okay
so i'll
i'll get started so when steve and i
were initially talking about this
question
he said you know you should really start
with asking the audience this
hypothetical question say you're looking
to have a one-night stand with somebody
and you're hiv negative
all else is equal between pat and jamie
would you choose pat who doesn't
who you don't know his or her hiv status
or jamie who claims to be hiv negative
for me of course i would choose
jamie right if all else was equal but a
few recent studies
that motivated our study suggested that
actually you should probably choose pat
which made no sense to me at the time
until i started thinking a little bit
more about it
and it has to do
with
a couple of things which i'll get into
more later but mostly it has to do with
the prevalence of men who are actually
hiv positive but undiagnosed
and think that they're negative
so that's kind of the
the punchline
so serosorting in the broadest sense is
partners making decisions based on their
assumed
or
perceived hiv status and their partner's
assumed or perceived hiv status so it
can really be negative with negative or
positive with positive we'll focus since
we're thinking about hiv prevention
primary prevention we'll be focusing on
negative with negative
but the trick is that serosorting is
based on the perceived status
whereas the bug you know transmission of
hiv depends on actual status so that's
the disjoint that makes this a really
interesting question
so as i mentioned there were two papers
that kind of motivated our paper
one
suggested that serosorting is actually
detrimental prevention strategy because
of the high viremia during the acute
stage of hiv and i have a few slides
later that we'll talk more about this
but essentially when someone first
becomes infected with hiv
they are more infectious
for to others they're more likely to
spread the disease
and the other paper
suggested that
when there's
low rates of testing are high
there's a high population among hiv
positive men who don't know that they're
positive then the serotonin can be risky
as well so this has to do with people
unaware of their infection which is also
a function of infrequent testing
or testing too early where you actually
get a false negative test
or for people who are undisclosed or
disclosed falsely
so those are the two papers
and then let me back up and just
motivate
why this is an interesting question
hiv in the united states the most recent
cdc estimates were from 2006 so they're
a few years old now
but they
predicted there were about 56 000 new
infections during the year
and among all the infections men and
women men who had sex with men
and bisexual men represented more than
half of those infections when you look
simply at hiv infection among men men in
sexual men represent more like three
quarters of the infection so they
men who have sex with men
disproportionately suffer from hiv in
the u.s that's just
a simple fact
recent surveillance also has showed
in seattle it's a little different but
nationally there's been a slight
increase in the number of hiv diagnoses
for msm and some people suggested that
that has to do with increases in
unprotected sex acts with people whose
serostatus is unknown
there's a lot of other research about
behavior once people are diagnosed with
hiv but i won't get into that at the
moment
and this particular study uses data from
seattle washington
in um um
the epidemic in seattle and white msm in
seattle prevalence is about 12 so 12 out
of 100 msm in seattle are infected with
hiv
and about 10 to 20 percent of those men
are thought to be
undiagnosed so they don't know they're
actually affected you know this i also
i'm not going to get into race and
ethnic differences in hiv but
in many other cities around the us
prevalence among msm is much higher and
among african-american msm it in some
places it's more like 40 to 50 percent
so it's really really a problem
okay
so sarah sorting zero sorting has been a
recent hot topic among academics but
it's nothing new for men of sex with men
men have been using condoms more often
with partners of discordant status so
when they know they're negative and
someone is positive
that's a type of serosorting and both
positive and negative men are more
likely to have sex with partners of the
same status so this has been going on
for a while
the academics have just kind of picked
it up recently
but in the in the public health world
it's been kind of a controversial issue
as to whether it's a good prevention
strategy or not
most epidemiologic studies suggest that
it offers partial protection
but as i mentioned these two modeling
studies suggested otherwise
and and for those reasons that i
mentioned high of eremia during the
acute stage and the high prevalence of
undiagnosed
infections
so that's why we decided to
do a more in-depth model to use
actual data data from seattle in our
model to try to answer the question
in our paper i should say the second
model came out at the same time ours did
so
i'll get to that i'll get to that later
okay so the aims of this talk and of
this paper are twofold
one is to evaluate the population and
individual level effects of sarah
sorting among msm in seattle so this
paper really focuses on just our
seattle epidemic
and secondly to define factors that
might influence how these
serotonin affects hiv transmission
dynamics so for those who are in the
modeling class yesterday the first is a
is a mathematical model and the second
is basically a sensitivity analysis
within the model
i always like talks where you get to
know the the result at the beginning so
you can think through it and the results
of our model is that sarah starting in
the context of men who have sex with men
in seattle where they test frequently
sarah sorting is a protective strategy
but if you look at our model and think
about rates of testing in other cities
it seems that that would definitely not
be the case in other cities where rates
of testing are not
as frequent
so
sarah sorting can be protected if men
test frequently therefore the
recognition of sterosaurin's importance
should prompt more frequent testing and
more sensitive assays
tests that pick up the infection earlier
basically
okay one last thing before we start um
getting into the paper is often when you
read about serosort in the literature
people kind of combine the definition of
sarah sorting as
having unprotected anal sex with
a partner of the concordant status but
that kind of mixes a couple of issues
together so we try to separate them and
and when i say serosorting i'm simply
referring to the use of serostatus in
selecting to have
anal sex or a sex act with that partner
but then we also separately look at
condom-based
sorry
status-based condom use which is the
differential adoption of whether or not
to use condoms by your partner's
perceived status
okay
i already said that so we keep them
separate
okay i should say if you guys have
questions in the middle please let me
know because i want to make sure that
the methods are clear
so that you can understand what i'm
assuming and what i'm what assumptions
i'm putting into the model
so so the methods that we use since we
we want to know the population level
effects of
individual level behavior it's hard to
really empirically measure that so we
use a model to try to simulate it we
decided to use a deterministic
continuous time mathematical model of
hiv transmission
and basically we we build a hypothetical
cohort of men
and we
we separate them into compartments where
they have similar characteristics in
those compartments and then we um
we identify a set of differential
equations
that determine the size of each
compartment so basically
how often men become infected how often
they decide to get tested how often they
adopt treatment etc
the compartments that we think are
important for this population are the
following
stage of hiv disease and that's because
we know that infection
infectiousness is higher early on
testing or the true knowledge of hiv
status that's a central
characteristic for our model since we
want to know men who are actually
positive but disclose as negative
antiretroviral treatment this is
especially important now since we know
that treatment really can be used as
prevention for
people who are
adherent to their antiretroviral
treatment they're much less infectious
to others so antiretroviral treatment is
both
good for the hiv-positive individual but
also for population level prevention and
lastly sexual activity level and this
was defined by the data that we used in
seattle we divide them into men who
well actually there's three categories
men who don't didn't have any anal sex
partners in the last year at all men who
had on average one partner in the last
year and everyone else and that and
everyone else basically had on average
10 partners in the last year
and that's actually a lot lower than um
it's it's lower than some other models
have assumed and i think our data is
actually correct so
okay
this is kind of a messy slide
but
but it's really informative so this is
time on the x-axis
and depending on what we're looking at
the y-axis is either cd4 cell counts
it's hiv-rna so this is actually the
virus
and notice that the x-axis isn't quite
continuous it's weeks weeks weeks and
then there's a break
and then this is years
so we know that viral load changes
dramatically over time as does
infectiousness
so when someone first becomes infected
these round dots are
our virus
the virus peaks and then your body kind
of gets a little bit of a handle of it
and can suppress the virus for a while
and we call this the acute stage of
disease when the body suppresses the
virus this um eight or so years
without treatment
is called the chronic stage and then
once the body is getting tired of all
the fighting that they're doing
virus starts to creep up again and this
is called the aids stage of disease
um
at the same time your cd4 cells or the
cells that are targeted by the virus
people without hiv have a high level of
cd4
the hiv virus starts to attack those
cells but then the body rebounds a
little bit
and then over time without treatment
your cd4 cell counts begin to drop
but so this is really an important time
to to consider the acute stage
although it's really difficult to unders
to get a good empirical estimate of the
probability of hiv transmission per sex
act
for many reasons it's hard to it's hard
to clearly get those data the one paper
that that has done this which is
actually a bit old now
comes from a heterosexual
study of
african men and women
and they basically showed that during
the first five months after
somebody became infected their
probability of transmitting hiv to their
partner is much higher than during the
acute st sorry the chronic stage so
acute stage is higher
about ten eight to ten times higher than
it is during the chronic stage and then
when virus starts to increase again so
does the probability of transmission
okay
testing
so
in seattle
well first let me say
we in the model assume that the acute
stage lasts about three months or 90
days
but there are different types of tests
that you can use to
see whether someone's hiv infected
most
health departments use what we call
antibody testing or eia testing
enzyme amino acid testing and these
tests search for the antibody in the
blood so you can only detect this once
the body has already produced enough
antibodies to be detectable and that
usually takes
seven weeks or so
so if this is your only test somebody
who gets infected and tests anywhere
between here with this test will get a
false negative
test even though they're actually
positive in seattle
they've started doing pooled rna testing
which actually tests for the virus
it's much more expensive
but it's much more sensitive so somebody
who is only a week or two in our model
we assume a week but someone a week or
two into the infection will actually get
a positive test
so i include both of these in the model
lastly i think before i introduced the
structure of the model um i wanted to
talk a bit about antiretroviral therapy
so we know the use of
especially highly active antiretroviral
therapy is very efficient in
suppressing the virus and and stopping
the progression of disease so
parameters actually i should probably
change this since i wrote this slide
parameters have changed as to when you
start your antiretroviral therapy
actually you guys probably already know
all this but basically
it usually starts when people have their
cd4 counts around 350. so it def it
in terms of hiv transmission dynamics
not only in terms of the person who is
hiv positive but in terms of population
level transmission dynamics art does two
things
first it extends the duration of
infectiousness so instead of being
without treatment someone lives on
average 10 12 years instead of being
infectious for only that period of time
they're infectious for however long they
live
but they are less infectious
there's a study
specifically among men who have sex with
men that suggest that men on
antiretroviral therapy
um uh antiretroviral therapy reduces
infectiousness by 60 percent however
some more recent studies suggest that
people that are adherent heterosexuals
adherent to antiretroviral therapy
reduces infectiousness by more like to
80 to 100 yeah um the
decrease is is that directional you know
though in other words
male male to female has decreased
80 to 100 percent or female to male i
was just wondering that's a good
question i i think they do
i'm thinking of connie callum's recent
paper
deborah dunnell and connie kelm and they
do they do report it by
by sex who's who's the infected partner
i i don't think it varied that much but
i don't have the numbers in front of me
i think it was for those that were
actually adherent
uh it was 90
and the
men who have sex with men you know the
top versus bottom line
it is lump i think this estimate has
them lumped together but that's a really
good question
okay
so this is the model
we talked about compartments yesterday
this is 12 compartments although
here i'm only showing the low activity
men there are 12 compartments for low
activity men and 12 compartments for
high sexual activity men
the first
row
is
the stage of disease
so men i didn't put births and deaths
here but imagine that birth people can
birth into the susceptible
box
and at any point people can die out of
any of these boxes
but this is the typical flow that people
can go that can age through the model
so peop men are born susceptible and
they're true negatives they become
infected through the lambda so this is a
really important parameter right here
this compartment is
the u the e and the y are the early and
acute stage
this compartment represents men who are
infected but no tests can pick up their
infection neither the rna or the
antibody test
men in this stage are hiv positive but
only the rna tests can pick them up
and men in this stage are in the acute
stage of hiv hiv positive and the
antibody test can pick them up that's
why
in either of these stages
they can get tested for hiv
if they don't get tested they have hiv
in the acute stage undiagnosed
undiagnosed they're chronically infected
undiagnosed
and then they're in the aid stage
undiagnosed untested untreated
however if they become if they take a
test they can come down to this row
these are all the men who are tested but
not yet on treatment
in the acute stage in the chronic stage
and in the age stage
additionally men can
start anti-ritual viral therapy
and would go down to this final row
these are men in the chronic stage so we
assume men in the acute stage don't go
on treatment
men in the chronic stage in the age
stage can be on treatment
so the important part of this
figure are the colors
these are the only men who are true
negatives
however all of these men
are apparent negatives so when they
disclose their hiv status they say
they're negative
although all of these men are positive
all of these men are diagnosed positive
and
disclosed as positive
however all of these men are positive
so that's kind of the key to this model
yeah sorry
do you just use birth as replacement for
death or how do you
um the rates of birth and death are
are the same so eventually this model
reaches an equilibrium okay yeah good
question
yeah sorry and do you distinguish
between
um
excuse me unaffected people who don't
know their status and
and disclose um
dishonestly no who just know that
they're negative versus they don't know
i mean the blue box is everyone oh oh oh
for the negatives
right that maybe yeah no we don't
we don't
so that that would be interesting to
think about how that would how that
would change
and change the results
right
right
and yeah so in
this is a subtle point that we wrote in
the paper but not in the topic
in our data we have men that report as
unknown
what we do with those men but in our
calculation of serosorting we either put
men into
apparent negatives or apparent positives
so with those unknowns we um wait we
disre distribute them
weighted by the actual prevalence in the
population
so
if there were 10 of unknowns out of 100
and there was 12 percent
hiv prevalence in the population 1.2 of
them would go into the positive box and
the rest would go into the negative
books
yes i'm sorry this is so interesting but
when you say birth and death equal
um i was just saying birth would be sort
of sexual debut yes and
the death rate for treated gay men in
the seattle area i would assume would
not be terribly high so oops
you said that you treat them as equal
nonetheless well so when i say treat
them as equal i i misspoke
death rates are different depending on
their hiv status
death rates are different depending on
if they're treated or not but if you
take all of the death rates together and
you average them that is equal to the
rate of people entering which is
actually sexual debut
so if you run this model for a hundred
years because those two rates on average
are equal
the prevalence reaches equilibrium
okay thanks for the questions this is
really
i think helpful okay
so as i said that this lambda is really
the heart of the
this whole model and hiv transmission is
a function in our model of
anal sex with the true positive
and this is a function of the contact
rate the number of partners that someone
has per year
the number of anal sex acts within a
partnership we don't model
any oral sex acts
um the condom use within the partnership
in the sex act and the position
top or bottom
for the serosorting the fraction of
apparent negatives who are actually
positives that's really important and
the level of serosorting which i'll show
you the data in a second so how often a
negative
man chooses another negative man as
opposed to a positive man yeah
so um in this model do you distinguish
between the receiver and the giver
yeah absolutely that's what i mean by
position yeah sterile position okay yeah
so the probability of transmission
depends significantly whether they're
receptive or insertive
and we have data on that as
a function of
serostatus as well
so that's all in there
a lot of the data i don't give you the
actual estimates but if you're
interested in building your own model of
hiv and you need to know
some of the assumptions that i use you
can go to the paper and there's also a
whole supplementary
appendix that you can look at that has
all of the data
okay and the data although it's a small
sample we're really proud that this data
this model is driven by data we don't
pull things out of the air and the data
come from
men in seattle
from a random digit dial if you know
anything about sampling you probably
think random digit dials have their
problems and they definitely do
but um
this was eight years ago and i guess one
benefit is that
cell phones weren't as popular eight
years ago as they are now i don't think
you could really do it now at all
but we have some some good data that we
use
and
here is the kind of the
the star of the show the odds of sarah
sorting for low activity respondents is
68 times
uh six the odds is 68 and the odds for
high activity men is lower but still
significantly higher than one
so this means that the odds of a low
activity
positive man
is 68 times more likely to choose
a positive partner than a
positive man is to choose a negative
partner
so that's what that that means
okay other data as i just mentioned i'm
not going to go into the details but
they're in the paper if you'd like to
know some of our point estimates for
these others
okay and a reminder that we separate
sarah sorting with the condom the status
based condom use
um and so let's get into some findings
if there's no other questions
yeah the question about your seattle
population you mentioned that seattle
has a higher testing rate
and then would you attribute that to
comparison to the rest of the country
i'll be going out on a limb because i'm
not an expert in this but i think our
public health department has done a good
job with the
not only promoting testing but promoting
the early kind of testing the uh the rna
testing
i know that socioeconomic status is
highly associated with testing and
there's major differences between the
msn population in seattle
um compared to baltimore do you see
and
sure
you're right there's um
much greater success for economic equity
in seattle you don't have the division
of wealth
that you have in other cities but um
another part of it is
a lot of
the testing
targets came in from seattle
uh largely because of the west coast
there's um
hiv
the difference between
burden of disease and male among msm and
other folks is much greater among msm on
the west coast
a lot of local funds go into testing
targeting gay men and they do
community-based customs as well
there's a storefront on
on pine street where you could in the
heart of the gay neighborhood where you
can just go and get tested by other gay
men for hiv and others for free for free
so
they
they deal with the problem
as well as they have the
resources thank you yeah
okay
so as i mentioned i want to look at the
population level and the individual
level here's the population level
so prevalence of
so basically i run this model two times
i run it with sarah certain equal to one
and then i run it with the odds of sarah
sorting equal to what we see in the data
when you run it with the the the data
driven model of the serosort and equals
to 68 and 12
prevalence
levels out at 16 percent which is close
to what you see in seattle
everything else equal you take away the
effect of serous sorting prevalence goes
up to about 24 percent so this suggests
that hiv prevalence would be higher
if men did not sarah sort
similarly at the individual level if you
randomly choose
a man to have unprotected anal sex with
who you think is negative
since some of them are positive you'll
have a risk of actually acquiring the
disease
so this is unprotected receptive anal
intercourse and this is unprotective
insertive anal intercourse
if men are serosorting you still have a
risk greater than zero of acquiring hiv
if you have sex with unprotected sex
with a parent negative but that's twice
as high as if there is no serosorting
same thing it's about twice as high for
the risk of unprotected insertive anal
sex
without sarah sorting so
in seattle both at the population and
into individual levels serosoning seems
to be a protective strategy
the unintuitive result that came out of
this model was that even though it's a
protective strategy in seattle
the proportion of infections that stem
from
undiagnosed men
is higher when men serosort
than when they don't
same with the proportion of recently
infected men
so that was really interesting this also
leads you to say serosorting may not be
a great prevention strategy on its own
it really should be coupled with testing
because you still get a huge amount of
infections stemming from men who are
undiagnosed
and this is this is so high because of
the acute stage of disease
is high
so the 30 of infections stem from newly
infected undiagnosed men
yeah can you go back one slide
so is this just the denominator effect
it's not i mean the proportion is higher
but the absolute number because the
overall number of infections is lower
with sarah's sorting
are you talking about this one or this
one and the one on the left uh-huh the
overall i mean the overall number of
infections is lower if you're starting
so if you go forward
oh i see what you're saying i mean it
might just be a
denominator effect right it might be
yeah
that you can look at the
proportion of infections the number of
infections
right undiagnosed right you might see
the reversal right absolutely you're
right
but it's still right even though it's
fewer infections overall
it may right that's a good point
yeah
i may have missed this but
you kind of you get de facto
so sorting by assault mixing by age
okay we don't include that in the model
okay
so yes
which is a good question given what we
talked about yesterday if i included age
as well it would make this model even
more
difficult
right
okay so now let's talk about some of the
sensitivity analysis
this is where i look at contact rate so
the x-axis here is the mean anal sex
contact formation rate or basically the
number of partners per year remember
that i mentioned there are two
populations that keep track of the low
activity people that have one partner on
average
and those that have 10 partners on
average when you weight them all
together the average is about 3.7
partners per year
and this line represents kind of the
baseline scenario
okay so the reason why i circled this is
because this is the baseline scenario
with serosorting prevalence is 16
all else equal you take away serosorting
prevalence goes up to 24 that's what i
showed you in the previous slide
however if you start to say okay what
happens if men start having more and
more and more sex partners
you see that once they have about seven
partners on average per year
the um
the the advantage disappears exactly
these lines cross
so another way to think about it is
sarah's sorting is more or less
equivalent to an 86 86 percent increase
in the number of partners
the protective effect
or
you see the same effect if you decrease
the number of partners you see the same
effect as if you didn't have serosorting
that's another way to think about it and
this is with the baseline rates of
condom use that we see in the model
but what about if
men didn't use condoms because a lot of
people think of serosaurus as a
prevention strategy in place of using
condoms so what if people sarah sorted
at the rates they told us but decided
not to have
protected sex within perceived sterile
concordant contact so when you think
your partner's negative and you're
negative you don't use condoms you see a
similar crossover but it happens much
sooner
so basically if men started having more
partners in seattle the effect would
would go away
more quickly
okay
so now let's look more closely at a
sensitivity around condom use
up here it's hard to read this is
economies in perceived discordant
contacts
and this is condom use in perceived
concordant context
in our model men in discordant contexts
where one is negative one is positive
use condoms about 30 percent of the time
it's really interesting actually when i
came across these i was confused at
first but men in perceived concordant
contacts use
condoms more often about 50 of the time
and i think that's the selectivity of
risk thing that's what
maybe
steve was telling me anyway so that's
the baseline so remember 16
here
16 here what happens if in perceived
discordant contacts you don't let anyone
use condoms or you make everyone use
condoms what happens to the effect of
serosorting
and as you can see there isn't really
much effect
you get about an eight percent drop in
hiv prevalence at the at the baseline
rates of economies but even if everybody
used condoms within the cereal
discordant contacts you would still get
about an eight percent benefit
however in
in perceived concordant contacts
where people think that they're having
a partner who is the same
hiv status as them the more that they
use condoms the bigger the protective
effect of sarah sorting which which
makes sense here it's about eight
percent
if everyone use condoms it goes to about
12 percent
if nobody use condoms
in these partnerships you still get a
slight benefit of sarah sorting remember
this is in seattle with the high rates
of testing
as you mentioned earlier and so here's
here's my last slide for the results
testing in our data high activity men
test more often because probably of
perceived risk they test on average
two times a year which is about every
six months
low activity men test about once a year
so this is the baseline
the 16 and 24. this is sarah sorting
scenarios this is no serious sorting
scenarios
what you see here is when you decrease
the frequency of testing so here test
low activity men tests every five years
and high activity men test every two and
a half years
the
the direction of the the
effect of serosodine is is opposite
or you don't have a difference right
actually i didn't i didn't test the
significance between that but so
basically
the the the theme is the less and less
you test
these bars start to change the
directions
and we didn't
explicitly model the proportion of
i always have to think through this when
i say the proportion of positive men who
are undiagnosed is directly of course
correlated with the frequency of testing
the other paper that came out within
weeks of our paper said if the
proportion of men who are positive and
undiagnosed 20 percent or higher
sterosauridin is a detrimental strategy
when men in seattle test about this much
the proportion of positive men who are
undiagnosed is about 12 13 14
so it's actually that our two papers
have similar conclusions we just looked
at it in different ways
when men test less frequently that
proportion of course increases
there was a
mmwr paper that came out last year that
surveyed men from
like sex venues and bars
and they found that in seattle
the seattle had and they tested men
in these venues
men in seattle had
about 10 to 20 were undiagnosed
positives whereas in baltimore and dc
that proportion was more like 40 percent
so
so that that makes sense if you try to
think about both of our papers
okay so let's let's finish up hiv
prevalence among msm in seattle would be
higher if men did not serosort according
to our model
but serosorting increases the proportion
of infections maybe not the absolute
number but the proportion of infections
transmitted from undiagnosed men
serosorting may not be as protective if
men have a higher average contact rate
condom use in perceived concordant
partnerships increases the benefit the
protective benefit of sarah sorting and
lastly sarah sorting may
be actually a detrimental strategy of
men do not test often
so really our our main finding of this
paper is that the recognition of sarah
sorting should promote the frequent more
frequent hiv testing i wouldn't go to a
health
department and say you should promote
serosorting as a standalone prevention
intervention that wouldn't make sense
but maybe if you package it with more
frequent testing
if men are doing it anyway condom use
more frequent testing
a few things that we didn't include in
our model and i'm sure you can think of
more
but we didn't include misrepresentation
of cerrostatus
this would probably reduce the
protective effect of sarasaran if men
lied about their status and in our data
it happened occasionally that men
reported to the survey that they had
lied previously in order to have sex
with a partner
not that often but it happened
motivation for testing in our test men
test on average every six months or one
year but in reality men probably test
a month after uh if they're not feeling
well if they recently had unprotected
sex or they test every year at regular
intervals our model doesn't explicitly
use that it's that kind of exponential
decline that we talked about yesterday
yeah um so when people are
misrepresenting their status
it's not just hiv-positive men that are
saying that they're negative it's hiv
negative men that are saying they're
positive
do you think that that is
i mean do you think some proportion of
that is due to
like a misunderstanding of their
diagnosis or did they say no actually
i
deliberately
misinformed my partner i don't know the
answer to that because do you come in
how many men would say if they had an
hiv-positive status
if they
had received a negative
yeah not often yeah i don't think that
happened this much
they're there um is a paper
i can't remember
which paper it is now
but they found that um
guys would report they would purport to
be negative to their partners
um a lot of the times the guys who are
positive would say yeah my last test was
negative but their last test was five
years ago
um and they'd been having unprotected
sex
so
you know
you'd way past the shelf life of those
negative tests
that that would reduce your possibility
right in fact and it wouldn't be
deliberate
misrepresentation right
right well there's also the unfortunate
thing of unchasing people who for one
reason or another
would deliberately
but that is so massive i think that's
not a progress it's so rare you know
where someone might misrepresent
themselves as negative to deliberately
get hiv you know you can find that
online but
i i don't think that's very
very common
and to misrepresent yourself as positive
i think
i'm sorry i just realized i forgot to
repeat the questions when they asked
them okay
so i'll try to do that if there are any
more questions
yeah
i was
wondering in the model does the
increased
testing
presumably would increase treatment and
in the model are they
you know linked
that wasn't you know you didn't
say that explicitly but i assume they
are right because the more people that
are in those second row of boxes which
represent the people who are diagnosed
positive the more they can then flow to
the third row of boxes which were
treated
it's it's a proportion of men who are
diagnosed
flow into the treated category so if
it's a hundred men and sixty percent
flow in that sixty of us two hundred men
and 60 percent flow in then it's 120. so
if that makes sense it's
would it be that low that people would
be diagnosed and and not you know
you know their
cd4 counts falling and they've refused
treatment
i i just threw that number
out of the hat
the data on the rate of
going on treatment and the rate of
withdrawing from treatment is in the
model
and i don't have it at the top of my
head
but it's in there yeah
i think that's the last slide right so i
just wanted to acknowledge my co-authors
as i said earlier this
project came out of a collaboration
between the uw
center for aids research and the public
health seattle lincoln county
health department and bob wood was the
outgoing director of the hiv aids
department matt golden is the ongoing
director and
we have a group in seattle that
it's basically a modeling group so i
wanted to thank them as well as my
co-authors and martina morris as well
so thank you so much